der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wartet globetrotter punkt ch
[Musik]
der äquator
er umfasst welten die unterschiedlicher
kaum sein könnten
in der millionenstadt singapur tauchen
wir ein in das leben der ärztin george
ali sie ist auch glamour girl und
millionärin
jetzt will sie mit ihrem
schönheitsprodukten asien erobern
in den weiten des pazifischen ozeans
liegt der inselstaat kiribati ein
paradies zum untergang verdammt für
jutta biener und ihrem mann wird ihr
geliebtes mehr zu gefahr
galapagos die insel der naturwunder eine
faszinierende welt im pazifik und die
heimat des touristen führers matthias
espinosa er kämpft dafür dass das
gleichgewicht zwischen tourismus und
natur auf seiner insel erhalten bleibt
und in kenia treffen wir auf eine junge
frau sie erhält die chance ihres lebens
[Musik]
in kenia verläuft der äquator direkt
über dem masai mara nationalpark einer
der berühmtesten safari destinationen
der welt
hier lebt auch das volk denn los sei und
merici serien
sie ist 20 jahre alt als einziger im
dorf macht sie eine ausbildung an einer
schule
sie möchte der safari guide für
touristen sein im moment hat sich ferien
und hilft daheim wie früher die kühe
sind das wichtigste für uns was sie
geben uns milch fleisch und leder
jeden morgen bei tagesanbruch kümmert
sich mary um die kühe zusammen mit den
anderen frauen aus dem dorf
ich liebe die kühe in die milch und das
fleisch kann ich verkaufen und damit
meine schule bezahlen wir hier keine kür
hatte ist ein armer mensch in dieser
hütte aus geflochtenem essen und kuhdung
lebt mary mit ihrer mutter hier ist sie
aufgewachsen
die mutter hat das häuschen selbst
gebaut ich muss aufpassen das wasser ist
nicht sauber
das sind insekten drin hier liebe ich
zusammen mit meiner mutter
wir haben zwei betten
so können wir uns gegenüber sitzen
nachts schlafen die ganz jungen kälbchen
auch noch bei uns internet zum frühstück
gibt es tee mit zucker und milch für
mehr reicht das geld nicht
[Musik]
mit elf jahren bekam er die chance eine
grundschule zu besuchen
[Musik]
sie lernte lesen schreiben und rechnen
ein privileg das nur wenigen masai
frauen vergönnt ist die ausbildung zum
safari guide ist für sie auch die
möglichkeit sich von der enge der
tradition zu befreien und mit etwas
glück ein neues leben zu beginnen
wenn ich die ausbildung schaffe werde
ich möglichkeiten haben im leben nicht
wie meine mutter
ich würde ein besseres leben haben als
sie vielleicht nicht viel besser aber
immerhin ein wenig besser doch bis es
soweit ist muss sie sich weiter den
traditionen unterordnen
[Musik]
wenige flecken auf dem äquator bieten
einen stärkeren gegensatz zur steppe
kenias als der stadtstaat singapur die
stadt der banker und der rohstoffhändler
der reichen und der schönen ein
perfekter ort für menschen wie dr
das ehemalige model dirigiert heute ein
beauty imperium mit kosmetik und
schönheitsbehandlungen hat sie millionen
gemacht
heute lässt sich georgia rund um die uhr
von mitarbeitern betreuen
damit sie immer ihrem schönheitsideal
entspricht
das leben ist stets prall gefüllt wie
ihr terminkalender das ist ihre
lebensphilosophie
das leben ist wie ein sandwich oben und
unten ein stück brot
das heißt wir kommen alle gleich zur
welt und am ende gehen wie auch wieder
gleich egal ob man reich ist oder arm
oder berühmt worauf es ankommt ist was
zwischen den booten ist man kann alles
mögliche rein tun wenn man mit einem
simplen sein wird zufrieden ist wieso
nicht
aber ich will dass mein sandwich voller
zutaten lässt
ich bin sehr gierig ich will dass mein
leben ein super bigmac oder ein super
klub sein witz ist charlie hat sich hier
super big mac leben hart erarbeitet bis
zu 80 stunden pro woche seien für sie
keine seltenheit
genießen sie die behandlung
ich will es versuchen das ist ein nicht
chirurgisch facelift die
ultraschallwellen dringen direkt in die
haut und muskeln und strafen sie george
ali macht schön mit allem was nicht
chirurgisch ist in singapur haben
zumindest die oberen zehntausend ein
unverkrampftes verhältnis zu
schönheitsbehandlungen aller art sagt
sie früher wenn man über botox oder
laser liften gesprochen hat haben viele
die nase gerümpft
heute ist das die neue art von
natürlichkeit
jetzt wird es etwas stärker ich spüre
frau doktor hat nicht viel zeit
dankeschön
es fühlt sich ein bisschen taub an ja in
den nächsten paar tagen werden sie so
einen gegenwind spüren
das ist normal weil die muskeln
stimuliert worden und weiter geht's im
terminplan noch vier patienten dann ist
frau doktor gastgeberin einer der
angesagtesten parties von singapur
[Musik]
rund 11.000 kilometer entfernt liegt das
land clippers so sieht ein paradies aus
die 33 atolle des inselstaates liegen
über eine fläche so groß wie die usa
verstreut mitten im pazifik die heimat
von 100.000 menschen ist aufgrund des
klimawandels dem untergang geweiht
doch das wissen hier nur wenige motto
bina und katar gehören nicht dazu
[Musik]
was sie merken ist dass der
meeresspiegel seit jahren steigt mit
jeder flut kommt das wasser ein stück
höher
ich habe das gefühl dass das mir jedes
jahr näher und näher kommen wenn das so
weitergeht wird es am ende noch unser
haus weg spielen katar und seine frau
jutta biener leben auf tuchfühlung mit
dem meer
und wenn es besonders wählt ist greift
es macht im land und nach ihrer hütte
jedes jahr ein bisschen mehr
ehrlich gesagt ich habe keine ahnung
warum das wasser immer näher kommt
vielleicht liegt es daran dass es mir
redner das von oben immer mehr
runterkommt und deshalb der
meeresspiegel steigt
ich weiß es nicht die menschen hier
haben weder radio noch fernsehen oder
internet deshalb wissen sie auch nichts
vom klimawandel den meeresspiegel
ansteigen lässt
[Musik]
oft kommt das wasser sogar bis zu
youtube ina in die küche
das passiert immer wieder
immer wenn die flut besonders hoch ist
dann steht hier drinnen alles unter
wasser
ich muss dann alle meine sachen hier
hoch tun damit es mehr sie nicht
wegspült
das muss dann ganz schnell gehen damit
nichts wegschwimmt oder kaputt geht was
liegt nur wenige zentimeter über dem
meeresspiegel und wird vom klimawandel
besonders hart getroffen wie hier 2011
klimaforscher warnen dass das land noch
in diesem jahrhundert unbewohnbar sein
wird oft habe ich angst dass das mehr
unser haus unter sich begraben könnte
wenn einer dieser stürme tobt und es
dringt und heute stelle ich mir vor dass
das was er uns eines tages mit hinaus
reist dann nehme ich meine enkelkinder
und zog er weiter weg vom mehr schutz
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
großvater kater zimmert an einem neuen
haus auf seine art will er seiner
familie mehr schutz vor der natur bieten
[Musik]
das neue haus wird ein paar meter weiter
weg vom meer stehen es wird größer und
stabiler sein als das alte
unser jetziges haus schwankt hin und her
wenn es stürmt das neue haus wird viel
mehr aushalten
doch dieser schutz nicht ausreichen
[Musik]
auf den galapagos inseln ist der anstieg
des meeresspiegels kein thema eine
wunderwelt genau auf dem äquator
das naturparadies gehört zu ecuador und
ist seit 1978 unesco weltnaturerbe
wenige menschen kennen die schönheiten
der inseln besser als matthias espinosa
[Musik]
matthias ist einer der gefragtesten
touristenführer von galapagos auch bill
gates hat seine dienste bereits in
anspruch genommen
wir sind dabei die verschiedenen arten
von landschildkröten aufs neue zu
untersuchen mit der neuen technologie
müssen wir unser altes bild über bord
werfen
alsmann blutproben von
riesenschildkröten hier nahm stellte man
fest dass es hier zwei arten von
schildkröten gang nicht nur eine die
eine im südwesten der insel und eine
andere mit nur 150 tieren auf der
nordostseite sie waren total isoliert
und das führte zu den verschiedenen
arten mit der einsamkeit ist das heute
allerdings vorbei galapagos und seine
tiere sind zu einem touristenmagnet
gewartet
[Musik]
toyota ist die einzige stadt auf
galapagos hier ist matthias zu hause
nach seinen ausflügen mit den touristen
kehrte ehemaliger journalist zurück in
sein haus am stadtrand
[Musik]
matthias vater war ecuadorianer seine
mutter deutsche
er kennt beide kulturen spricht beide
sprachen
[Musik]
das gemeinsame mittagessen nimmt
matthias mit seiner frau maria augusta
einer biologin und seinen beiden söhnen
tee und dani 1
viel zeit zum austausch bleibt den
beiden nicht überhaupt muss das
familienleben oft zurückstecken
die nächsten touren stehen an und sind
bereits ausgebucht
matthias liebt es an einem ort zu leben
von dem andere oft ein leben lang
träumen wenn du jeden tag in dieser
wunderschönen natur ist bleibt ihr
nichts anderes übrig als sich in diese
natur zu verlieben
das ist ein großes der zu hause du hast
jeden tag eine wunderschöne natur wenn
du vom boot raus gehst und tauchen uns
locken gehst und land besuchen machst du
bist ein auserwählter der zufall es
geschafft hat hier zu leben und
signieren zu lassen und das ist ein
großes geschenk
matthias hat sich eine tauchschule
aufgebaut über sie bietet er jetzt eine
reise zu einem ganz besonderen highlight
an
[Musik]
in caritas warten kater und seine
familie wie jeden morgen auf die elbe
jutta biener nutzt die zeit für ein
gemeinsames frühstück mit ihren
enkelkindern
[Musik]
die eltern sind unterwegs
also kümmern sich die großeltern um die
kinder
die namen des vaters des sohnes und des
heiligen geistes
lieber gott bitte unsere speisen
[Musik]
mal
hier
[Musik]
so schmeckt es ist ein leben im rhythmus
von ebbe und flut seit generationen
das meer hat für uns eine große
bedeutung
es gibt uns nahrung und auch eine
finanzielle grundlage zum leben von
meinem haus aus kann ich jederzeit sehen
ob er isst oder und wenn ebbe ist gehe
ich hinaus unsere firma die kann ich
dann anschließend verkaufen
[Musik]
noch ist die elbe nicht an ihren
tiefsten punkt es bleibt zeit sich
gedanken über die sicherheit zu machen
ich denke du solltest deinen schutzwall
da unten verstärken sonst macht die
nächste flut in wieder kaputt meinst du
nicht
mit bescheidenen mitteln versuchen kater
und youtube ina ihr zuhause vor den
angriffen des meeres zu schützen so gut
es geht
und das ist der einzige schutz den wir
haben
ich starte die strähne hier aufeinander
wenn die flut dann kommt trifft sie auf
den schutzwall und richtet an land
weniger schaden an
das mache ich jeden tag aufs neue
ein ritual zwischen mensch und natur
tag für tag manchmal habe ich die
schnauze voll das ganze immer wieder
aufzubauen
ich weiß das ist kein wirklicher schutz
das meer macht ihn jedes mal wieder
kaputt aber das ist das einzige was ich
tun kann was soll ich denn sonst machen
hier sind sie geboren und hier wollen
sie bleiben
wir sind glücklich ich sage immer wieder
zum 1 wir lieben unser zuhause
lasst uns kämpfen ist gegen das meer zu
verteidigen
doch schon in den nächsten tagen werden
die beiden erfahrungen machen die ihre
einstellung für immer verändern werden
[Musik]
in kenia ist mary unterwegs zu dem ort
der eheleben vor neun jahren grundlegend
verändert hat die cia boarding school
sie und ihre schwestern sind die
einzigen aus ihrem dorf die hier
zwischen gehen durften
alles ist noch so wie früher das ist
mein alter klassenraum
es gibt hier aus champions und victor's
es gibt drei klassen damit es genügend
platz hat für alle kinder
ich war bei den champion
hier habe ich jeweils gesessen aber das
pult war damals noch schulden nicht so
kaputt
ich weiß nicht wer es kaputt gemacht
sagt mal wer hat denn das bürgerpark
gemacht war das natürlich niemand
mary war so alt wie diese schüler als
sie beschnitten wurde und verheiratet
werden sollte jetzt besucht sie den mann
der zumindest die hochzeit verhindert
hat schuldirektor de bieten kann setzt
sie seit vielen jahren gegen
beschneidung und gegen zwangsheirat 1
wie läuft's mit der ausbildung gut danke
du musst die beste sollen dann bekommst
du einen guten job
der direktor kämpft für eine bessere
stellung der frau bei den massai in der
massenkultur sind mädchen wertlos sie
sind nur darum verheiratet zu werden
sie dürfen auch nichts besitzen und sie
dürfen nichts kosten
wenn man den leuten sagt sie sollen ihre
mädchen in die schule schicken
ist das für sie vor allem ein
geldverlust wir versuchen nur mit den
leuten zu reden
vor allem auch über die kirchen in den
liedern sagen wir den leuten wenn du ein
mädchen aus bildest bildest du ein
ganzes dorf aus als der schuldirektor
damals vom schicksal der 11 jährigen
mary hörte zögerte er nicht lange
ich bin sofort zu ihr nach hause
gegangen und habe sie hier gut ihr
bruder hafte markt stimmt ja ich sagte
ich nehme sie mit die zweite frau des
bruders er hatte zwei frauen sagte das
geht nicht mein mann ist nicht da ich
sagte ihr sagt einem mann er kann in die
schule kommen
mary habe ich mitgenommen der bruder kam
sehr schnell
er sagte mir lehrer last dieses mädchen
gehen
sie ist bereits versprochen ich gebe dir
was immer du willst alles auch geld ich
habe ihm gesagt ich will dein geld nicht
ich will dass du dieses büro verlässt
oder ich rufe die polizei
ich glaube mein leben wäre schrecklich
geworden aber ich wurde gerettet dafür
bin ich sehr dankbar
ich bin sehr glücklich dass ich keine
kinder habe um die ich mich kümmern muss
keinen mann der mich schlecht behandelt
jetzt gibt es nur mich und die bücher
für eine bessere zukunft
mary wurde in vielen fächern
klassenbeste von ihrem bett aus
schmiedete sie bereits damals große
pläne für die zukunft
und jetzt sind ihre träume zum greifen
nah
[Musik]
in der millionenstadt singapur hat die
45 jährige georgia die einen großen teil
ihrer träume bereits verwirklicht
sie ist eine angesehene schönheits
ärztin und eine prägende figur in
singapurs mode und beauty welt so ist
ihre party heute das jetset event der
millionenstadt
[Musik]
mit dabei auch hier ihre entourage aber
auch in ihrer durchgestylten welt gibt
es probleme die passenden schuhe sind
nicht da ihre haushälterin muss helfen
hast du die schuhe gefunden es war
einfach zu finden gibt sie erwähnt sie
haben meine schuhe gefunden
da bin ich wirklich sehr pingelig alle
meine schuhe sind alphabetisch nach
marken geordnet meine haushälterin ist
schon 18 jahre bei mir und kennt meine
sachen sehr gut
wenn george ruft kommen sie alle
mode designer stylisten kunden und
geschäftspartner
[Musik]
[Applaus]
frei nach dem motto 'jetzt schriller
desto besser
[Applaus]
das ist die andere frau doktor
[Musik]
[Applaus]
george ali die society-lady
[Musik]
jedem gibt sie das gefühl dass sie oder
er besonders wichtig ist
gott sei dank doch noch in den passenden
schulen das ist der rhythmus von
singapur
sie sehen fantastisch und ich kann fast
niemanden sehen
vielen dank fürs kommen
ich möchte meinem team danken dass an
mich glaubt und alle meine visionen mit
mir teilt er reißt euch den arsch auf
damit wir erfolg haben
ihr seid alle wie disco ihr seid
unsterblich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf galapagos suchen die menschen mehr
die nähe zu natur und tieren meist zur
party touristenführer matthias ist mit
seiner gruppe unterwegs zu einem
highlight am äquator den seelöwen
doch die lieben allerdings noch faul am
strand und lassen sich die sonne auf den
pelz brennen
erst im wasser werden die sonnenanbeter
zu virtuosen der bewegungskunst
[Musik]
dorthin müssen sie erst mal kommen
ihr teilen sie sich mit weißspitzen
refrain
beide haben es auf die gleiche beute
abgesehen
für den engagierten tierschützer
matthias ist der bevorstehende tauchgang
mit seinen touristen mehr als nur eine
tierschau wir müssen realisieren wie es
den seelöwen geht weil sie lesen leiden
sehr unter niño phänomen das heißt das
wasser warm wird oder in der letzten
zeit ist die bevölkerung der seelöwen
von galapagos etwas runtergegangen und
erforschen warum unter wasser trifft
matthias zunächst auf einen riesigen
schwarm galapagos doktorfische an den
drei schwarz weißen punkten vor dem
gelben schwanz befinden sich
messerscharf skalpelle so scharf jene
von chirurgen deshalb der name
doktorfische
matthias bleibt geduldig und sein warten
mit belohnt denn plötzlich sind sie da
die seelöwen
[Musik]
die trägen sonnenanbeter vom strand
unter wasser sind sie balletttänzer
sondergleichen
[Musik]
spielerisch nähern sie sich dem
eindringling in ihr reich und
spielerisch studiert matthias ihr
verhalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der tauchgang ist zu ende matthias ist
was den bestand der seelöwen angeht
beruf nicht ganz toll und es war eine
große bevölkerung von jungen löwen also
dieses jahr steht es doch ziemlich gut
mitziehen
doch auch an land drohen dem
naturparadies gefahren auf schiri boss
hat sich das meer inzwischen
zurückgezogen
zeit für jutta biener die
lebensgrundlage für ihre familie zu
erwirtschaften
es ist mittag mehr als 40 grad
das meer scheint jetzt ganz weit weg
erst wenn es aussieht wie eine wüste
kann jutta biener ihm das entreißen
wovon ihre ganze familie lebt sie würmer
gebraten sind sie auf clippers eine
delikatesse
an guten tagen verdient jutta biener
damit bis zu 10 franken
[Musik]
mehrere stunden verbringt jutta biener
unter der brennenden sonne
dadurch rennen man muss dort graben wo
die luftlöcher sind und dann mit dem
spieß rein
mit der erfahrung weiß man genau wie das
geht gotovina ist stolz auf ihre arbeit
dass würmer fangen hat mir meine
großmutter beigebracht mein mann hat nur
wenig arbeit
früher war ich mir meiner fähigkeiten
nicht so bewusst aber jetzt merke ich
dass ich da eine wunderbare begabung
habe schauen sie sich um ihr das alles
ist sozusagen mein büro
ich bin glücklich hier ein leben im
rhythmus mit der natur
[Musik]
so ist sie aufgewachsen und so möchte
sie dereinst auch sterben
für jutta biener undenkbar dass das meer
dies alles verschlingen könnte
natürlich merke ich dass der
meeresspiegel ansteigt
aber dass das alles hier verschwinden
soll das die ganze insel mit allem drum
und dran einfach untergehen soll
nein das kann ich mir beim besten willen
nicht vorstellen
doch schon morgen wird sie erfahren wie
sehr das meer ihre existenz bedroht
[Musik]
auf galapagos hingegen bedroht der
mensch die natur
matthias ist besorgt dass immer mehr
einwohner aus ecuador auf galapagos ihre
häuser bauen
die einwohnerzahl des hauptortes puerto
ayora hat sich verzehnfacht
matthias betrachtet den bauboom auf
seiner insel mit wachsender sorge
[Musik]
man sieht natürlich hinter mir wie das
dorf zu einer stadt geworden ist und wie
die leute natürlich sich niederlassen
und auch öfters sehr einfach leben
darunter sind auch viele leute die die
nicht so verstehen was galapagos
bedeutet man muss noch viel in dem
gebiet umwelterziehung machen so viele
leute lieben mit einem gemisch von
eingeführten tieren und eingeführten
pflanzen und verstehen noch nicht so
richtig was galapagos für eine bedeutung
hat in der welt als einmalige insel die
neuzuzüger bringen häufig haustiere vom
festland mit auf die inseln
besonders wenn sie verwildern stellen
sie eine bedrohung dafür die tierarten
von galapagos
eines der grossen ziele von matthias er
will sich dafür einsetzen dass sein
königreich der natur nicht zum
ferienparadies aller disneyland verkommt
wieder einmal muss matthias abschied
nehmen von seiner familie eine woche
lang wird der touristen während einer
kreuzfahrt zu den größten highlights von
galapagos führen auch wenn ihm der
abschied schwer fällt
matthias herz schlägt neben der familie
eben auch für die einzigartige natur von
galapagos
[Musik]
in kenia bleiben mary nur noch wenige
ferientage bis sie an die schule
zurückkehrt so kann sie ihrer mutter bei
ihrer schweren körperlichen arbeit
helfen die holz last ist für den hausbau
in ein nachbardorf bestimmt das ist ganz
schön schwer
früher habe ich das oft gemacht auch
maries mutter packt mit an
20 minuten fußmarsch sind es bis ins
nächste dorf bei 40 grad mit mehreren
kilo holz auf dem rücken
körperliche arbeit überlassen die masai
gerne den frauen die männer verbringen
den tag lieber im schatten eines baumes
hier lässt sich wunderbar über alles
reden auch über frau wie viele kinder
haben deine frau ja innerhalb fünfte
unsere zwei frauen wie mary sind den
meisten männern an dorn im auge
sie fürchten dass durch bildung der
frauen die traditionelle
rollenaufteilung ins wanken geraten
könnte
junge frauen wie mary und zur schule
gehen tragen dazu bei
wenn die mädchen zur schule gehen gibt
es ärger genau
wir sind gegen die schule weil die
frauen dann selbstbewusster werden
am ende wollte da noch die scheidung
inzwischen kann mary das verhalten der
männer etwas lockerer sehen
sie ist auf bestem weg den sozialen
zwängen der masai zu entkommen
dank ihrer ausbildung als
touristenführerin wird sie mit etwas
glück ein eigenständiges leben führen
können
da wären wir auch wenn die mutter damals
der beschneidung und der zwangsheirat
zugestimmt hat heute ist sie froh dass
es anders gekommen ist
ich bin glücklich dass meine tochter zur
schule geht
sie wird an guide in einem nationalpark
und so geld verdienen wie kann ein gutes
leben haben etwas besitzen und mir
später unterstützen doch bis es soweit
ist hat mary noch einige hürden zu
nehmen
[Musik]
matthias espinosa ist inzwischen vor der
insel isabela angekommen
er macht sich gemeinsam mit den
touristen bereit zu einem besonderen
tauchgang mit etwas glück sollen sie
heil und barrakudas zu sehen bekommen
mit dem beiboot geht es zum tauchsport
oder das naturschauspiel wartet
[Musik]
und dann tatsächlich ein weißspitzen
rifai
eindrücklich aber zumindest für den
menschen ungefährlich
[Musik]
der giftige skorpions fisch schaute im
unterwasser tourismus gelassen zu
unter wassergeister äquator nicht mit
seinen reizen
matthias kommuniziert seinen
tauchtouristen da drüben barracudas ein
riesiger schwarm
wie von unsichtbarer hand gesteuert
öffnet und schließt sich der verband um
die taucher
eine symphonie dirigiert von meistro
natur und doch nur die ouvertüre zum
auftakt
[Musik]
der morgen nach der großen party in
singapur
es ist sonntag
heute will sich georgi zeit für ihre
familie nehmen
in der nächsten folge erleben wir die
ärztin und glamour lady privat als
ehefrau und mutter in kenia macht sich
mary hübsch für die schule
auf galapagos entführt matthias seine
touristen zu urtieren der besonderen art
und in kiribati otto bihler dass ihre
heimat untergehen wird
dies und mehr in der nächsten folge von
der äquator
breitengrad der extreme
der äquator mit globetrotter darm
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte die
reisewelt wie globetrotter punkt ch